make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin all right what's going on
guys this is rob and we are picking back
up again with avengers and new avengers
and what we're doing here is we're
picking up a little bit in the aftermath
of infinity right not i guess not really
immediately after infinity took place
but specifically
the whole detonation of the terrigen
bomb now for those of you guys who never
saw the infinity event you had two
stories going on at the same time right
the main story focused on thanos
basically trying to acquire his son
ultimately locating him and then once he
was discovered his son's you know
power is more or less activating when
black bolt and thanos fought and the
reason why that matters is because
in the process black bolt basically
destroyed the or i guess uh detonated
the terrigen bomb which would spread the
terrigen myths across the world and so
those individuals out there in the world
who were inhumans and simply didn't know
suddenly had their inhuman powers
activated now thanos of course found a
son and you can find out what happens
with the rest of that story
down in the description but the idea
here is that in the aftermath of that
because thanos had basically beat black
bolt within an inch of his life
black bolts been recovering with his aid
or with the aid of of his brother
maximus the mad and so with black bolt
basically recovering
the idea here is that with all these
different inhumans waking up across the
world the intention is to basically
travel around the world
and to gather these inhumans together
and bring them under the control of the
royal family the funny thing about this
is that you actually go into an event
from marvel comics called inhumanity and
inhuman uh which really sees everything
but that happening
it's actually a pretty cool line of
comics i don't think we ever really
covered it i want to say it was charles
soule
who wrote it and it was great right but
from there we switch over to wakanda
right and we pick up with black panther
and black panther here is basically
struggling with this inner turmoil right
the fact that he doesn't really consider
whatever this action is to be weakness
that it's not really doubt that he knows
who he is but the very idea of what he's
pondering here right the very idea of
what he's considering
destroying a world is something that
he's wrestling with on a moral scale and
the people he's talking to
are basically his ancestors now here's
an important thing that i want you guys
to understand that i want you guys to
know about if you saw the black panther
film in the marvel cinematic universe he
was communicating with his ancestors in
the afterlife this was not a thing that
black panther could do until jonathan
hickman was writing the fantastic four
and he introduced the idea that with
shuri becoming the new black panther
after the events of doom war and
t'challa basically being forced to step
down
that t'challa gained a new source of
power and becoming the king of the dead
and what that meant was he could now
communicate and talk to his ancestors so
that's why this happens here
that's why you see it in the mcu it's a
relatively new thing and so
communicating
and talking to his ancestors is an
interesting concept because he basically
kind of
you know kind of espouses this idea and
when they ask what are you struggling
with he basically says in the next
hour there's going to be another
incursion and when that happens
our world is going to face off or is
going to come face to face with another
world
that houses not villains or evil
individuals but people who are actually
heroes like us they're good guys they've
done good for their world this will be
the first time that we have an incursion
where we have to face a threat like this
and my concern here is that we may end
up having to destroy these people's
worlds and the response of his ancestors
is
so and it's like it's the coolest
response because he's like what do you
mean
so right like like i've done murder i've
done terrible things and i've done it in
a way where i've been king and i've did
what i needed to do but there's a
difference between
taking out individuals who are a
credible threat to wakanda and taking
out what are basically innocent people
right because the reality of this is
if they over if they face off against
the great society and a conflict breaks
out
and they have to destroy the world of
the great society it's not just those
heroes who die
it's billions of men women and children
across the surface across that world who
die as well
right people who don't even know what's
going on who are going about their
normal lives and then suddenly
the world just ends right like that's
what we're talking about here and the
the response
of this really comes by way of black
panther's father himself right to chaka
and he basically says here's the thing
to understand
right this is you you are of wakanda you
are a king
of wakanda you have to understand the
price that comes with that right heavy
is the head that wears the crown
the question you have to ask here is
over the time that our kingdom has been
in existence over the time that wakanda
has been
alive how many people have we turned
away how many people who were seeking
refuge have we told you can't come here
because it was important to keep our
society safe and secret and hidden away
from the world how many times have we
done that and and how many men women and
children did we kill by virtue of that
but it's what was best for our kingdom
it's what was best for our people and he
says that's what you're facing here
anything that could be a threat to
wakanda is a threat worth destroying
that's the way it is that's how wakanda
is that's how the ancestors of black
panther saw it that's how black panther
himself
is being told to see it if it's a threat
to wakanda then it needs to go
so sure you're gonna wipe out a world of
however many billions of people if you
decide to detonate an anti-matter bomb
on that earth but the reality is either
it's them or it's you
and and as a king your job is to protect
your people which means to choose
yourself it means to choose our earth
and destroy theirs in the process
if they have a problem with it sorry
about your luck wouldn't want to be in
your shoes that's just the way it goes
and so again it's it's intriguing here
because one of the things is kind of
asked here
at the at the very last moment you know
when all the other ancestors have
basically departed is t'chaka pulls his
son aside for a second and asks him
there's one last thing
have you killed the atlantean yet right
have you killed neymar the submariner
now for those of you guys who don't know
what that's about we talked about that
earlier when we began the the avengers
and new avengers series you should check
out the avengers vs x-men event when
neymar was part of the phoenix force he
basically destroyed a huge portion of
wakanda
so because he had committed such an
offense against the wakandan people
that's why the ancestors are asking the
other part of this
is doctor strange basically reappears
right after having been at the center's
market now we will learn more about that
what we end up doing at this point is we
jump to bruce banner and we jump to
beast now again bruce banner is the new
kid on the block he was just recently
brought into the illuminati team in
order to
basically help them uh figure out what
to do right because the reality is with
all the different ideas they have
they've yet to come to a solid solution
and bruce banner has a unique mind
insofar as he's the most knowledgeable
when it comes to gamma radiation but
he's also considered to be one of the
smartest man in the world and so the
notion here is
maybe he can help them think of
something that they haven't really
thought about before but to show you
guys
just how far things are at the moment we
basically pick up
with tony stark and tony stark is having
a conversation with black swan and
basically saying here's what's going to
happen right i have just
constantly been perplexed by this
problem i've constantly been perplexed
by this idea of what's going on with the
incursions and you giving us these these
answers basically telling us there's
nothing we can do
that that either we can destroy other
worlds and hope we survive to the end or
we just perish you know when one of the
other worlds destroys us but at the end
of the day there's nothing we can do to
stop it and as his whole eye
the stance of tony stark here is he's a
futurist right he's the idea man if tony
stark can't think of it it cannot be
solved that's just the way that it works
that's just how his mind works he
is in the most extreme degree a guy who
solves
problems and and and from what he's
being told by black swan who seems to
have this information that she's just
not revealing to tony stark that there
is no way to solve the problem right
there's nothing that they can do and
this is why tony stark is getting so
frustrated because the the question she
asks
she asks are you are you so sure that
this is the problem or do you think the
real problem
is that you're simply just in denial
you're simply refusing to accept the
fact that there is nothing you can do
but every single threat you've ever
faced in your life as a superhero up to
this point
has been some physical tangible person
you can fight against right you know
galactus shows up on earth and you guys
threaten with the ultimate nullifier or
you grab the help of the silver surfer
or just through sheer force of will you
manage to topple him right thanos shows
up you guys fight him off this villain
shows up you fight this villain shows up
you fight it's a tangible thing that's
been your
life you always overcome the odds you
always come out on top but for the first
time in your life tony stark you guys
are facing off against a threat that
cannot be
solved with mathematical formulas it
cannot be fixed with some infinity
gauntlet there's nothing you can do
there's no day to be saved here your
days are numbered when that number comes
to zero there'll be nothing left and you
along with everything that you know is
going to die tony
just cannot accept that fact right and
so what he basically you know really in
his paranoia i would say
ends up stepping up and saying here's
what's going to happen we're going to
deal with this incursion right
we're going to cope with this incursion
and do whatever in the hell we have to
do in order to basically end it but then
following that i'm going to bring in a
telepath
i'm going to have somebody like emma
frost come in here and probe your mind
i'm going to have them you know
basically
tear your mind apart and find out
everything you know we're gonna go
through every scrap of information we're
gonna go through everything that we can
to find out what this truth is and her
whole idea here is i've never lied to
any of you i have never ever lied to a
single one of you and she gives the best
response here right tony asks have you
ever heard of lies of omission and she
says yes
that's what the ignorant people call
displays of their ignorance
right you want to believe there's
something there because you're too
stupid to accept the fact that there's
not that's what's so cool
about this right she's such a great
character she's so wildly interesting
and so of course with tony stark
storming off this leads to reed richards
being there and he kind of asked her
what in the world was going on and she
says
it's just a man coming to the end of
himself right tony stark coming to the
realization
there's nothing he can do there's
nothing he can offer here that all of
his blunted intelligence and all of his
gadgets and all of his iron man armors
they're useless in the face of all this
and so from there
we pick up with basically the illuminati
team showing up on the alternate reality
earth right the the great society
earth and as soon as they arrive it's
kind of funny because the great society
sort of looks up and says okay
like we don't really know what this is
right they're not black priests they're
not like they're not map makers
we don't really know what these guys are
you know are they are they peaceful like
we are or are they monsters like we
don't know
what the deal is here and that's what's
kind of cool is because as soon as the
the illuminati show up the great society
greet them as friends and this is
this is a really interesting concept
right because you see this
this is exactly what the justice league
would do right the justice league would
approach trying to attain diplomacy that
fighting would be a last resort and much
like what sun god's doing right now
superman would do the same thing and he
would say okay like let's see if there's
a way for us to talk this out right if
there's
any other character in marvel they would
just start fighting right like marvel's
violent man like all the superheroes in
marvel are just
mean man like we're just gonna fight you
first and then like we'll ask some
questions along the way and then if over
the course of this fight we realize
you're the good guys then we'll stop
right like marvel superheroes are kind
of dicks
to be honest with you guys
[Laughter]
they really kind of are i love marvel to
death been reading them for 25 years but
they're
kind of dicks like it's just the way the
superheroes are written and i
love it right so uh one of the things
that kind of goes into this
is you have of course wayne right the
the pasticha batman basically the
marvel version of batman who kind of
says like how can we trust you right and
more important than that how do you know
you can trust us
and the response of beast is we've been
watching you right we constructed a
bridge that let us look into alternate
realities and we came across your world
because you survived two incursions and
they say no
we actually saw we we survived three and
it's kind of okay but we only saw two so
so what you end up getting here is
this little degree of an explanation
that when the questions asked by reed
richards one of these incursions you
survived you survived by basically
moving your universe out of phase right
that you more or less made your universe
intangible right the way the vision
makes himself intangible so if you throw
something at him it'll just pass right
through him that's what they did with
their universe that instead of allowing
the the earth to crash into each other
they move their universe out of phase so
basically the other earth and the other
universe they just pass right through
each other and when they ask
how do you do that like how are you able
to pull that off they said we're using
something called the wishing box now
here's my mistake i originally thought
they were talking about a cosmic cube
and i didn't i totally forgot
that like there are different all you
know really alternate reality versions
of infinity stones right and that's what
they basically say right it's basically
a cube that's made up of six planes of
forever glass basically these these this
kind of material this made up of the
fabric of the universe it's an infinity
gauntlet it's really all it is now this
is why this is kind of cool because in
marvel comics as far as i'm aware this
is the first time we've seen an
alternate reality version of the
infinity gauntlet that does not look
like the gauntlet
traditionally in marvel comics no matter
what universe you're talking about when
when marvel references the infinity
gauntlet
we basically get a glove with infinity
stones on it and the reason why is
because it's recognizable right like
people see that and like oh that's the
infinity gauntlet in this day and age
because of the events of avengers
in-game and like avengers infinity war
you see anybody walking down the street
or you go to a con and you see a
gauntlet you immediately know what it is
and even comic book readers were just
like i know exactly what that is that's
the infinity gauntlet everybody knows
what it is it's so recognizable and it
makes sense that in almost any other
alternate reality story
you would see it designed the exact same
way just being wielded by somebody under
a different circumstance and this
reality that it's basically just forever
glass right it's just five
five pieces of glass that come into the
shape of a cube which really begs the
question is this the same thing as a
cosmic hue
right what would happen if you combine
the power of a cosmic cube with an
infinity gauntlet right what would that
look like uh honestly i don't really
think you'd see a difference right i
mean if you can
you know basically use the cosmic cube
to do the exact same thing that you
would do with an infinity gauntlet then
what's the difference right i mean i
guess maybe you can do it like
twice as fast or you can like do it
twice as much i don't know
like infinite power times two i don't
really know how you how you
mathematically quantify infinity uh by a
factor of two i don't really know
if you even can do that i'm not a
mathematician i'm sure one of you guys
out there on the rob corps went to like
mit or something like that and you're
good with maths
but uh the whole thing here is that
there's a lot of of
uncertainty i guess is the best word to
use ryder is
highly skeptical of the superheroes
right he's highly skeptical of the
illuminati and says okay
here's the issue though you show up on
our doorstep and you tell us that you
come bringing peace that you're here for
a peaceful resolution but here's the
problem
we've roughly got about seven and a half
hours before both our universes end
because the earths are going to crash
into each other and where iron man
and and reed richards and all these guys
are talking about different ideas
then the question becomes okay uh what
are these ideas that you have
and what happens if they fail and that's
kind of that's that's when black panther
basically speaks up and says
we have a plan right we have an
anti-matter bomb we basically built this
bomb to destroy an entire world and
that's when reid's kind of like are you
guys sure you don't have anything and
sun gods like i already told you we have
hope right we have hope
that things will get better and that's
when neymar kind of makes fun of him
says well i hope you can come up with
something better than hope
right like because this is a serious
time and we kind of need a serious
solution
we don't need this justice league
philosophy of resting on your laurels
and just hoping things get better
and that's enough no we need like actual
solutions to a problem and that's what
that's what what makes this interesting
right kind of these you know two
diametrically opposing views now
something else that i want to throw
throw to your attention that's kind of
going on here at the same time and it's
very easy for us to kind of skip over it
but we're not going to
maximus the mad is a very interesting
character in reality he is in a lot of
ways similar to the joker his schemes
don't really make sense to anybody but
himself but what he's come to realize
is that with everything happening
they're going to need all hands on deck
and there are some individuals who had
been defeated at the hands of the
avengers or whoever
they're wildly powerful albeit evil and
they are going to be needed
what max the the mad does here is he
basically fires up a high-powered laser
and with the help of black swan
starts to crack the the you know
containment containment device that
holds thanos
and the black order maximus the mad is
freeing the free the mad titan
and the black order this is cool corvus
glaive proxima midnight
all these characters maximus the matter
setting them loose like he's getting
ready to just let them return back
and do their thing and so because of all
this you know with you know kind of
switching back to the avengers and
i guess to the illuminati in the great
society things kind of keep going back
and forth right
it's this constant kind of conversation
that's going on namor is losing patience
right
because you basically have them stalling
the inevitable well surely we can come
up with an idea surely there's something
we can do
we can talk this out what if we don't
succeed are you going to destroy our
world well i mean we don't want to
destroy your world and they're more or
less beating around the bush right it's
more or less the illuminati kind of
beating around the bush and instead of
outright saying
if things go south we're going to blow
your world to smithereens it's kind of
like well
it won't come to that we'll find a
solution we'll find a way to make it
work all this kind of going back and
forth
neymar is getting very agitated and very
irritated and in that frustration
he takes his trident throws it at ryder
and basically says here's what's gonna
happen guys i'm tired of waiting for the
inevitable the inevitable is that
none of us are gonna be able to come up
with a solution in the span of eight
hours that's going to spare both of our
worlds if i am going to become this
thing whatever this thing is this evil
human being this person is willing to
cast aside the lives of billions of
people to protect himself
then by god i'll do it at a time of my
choosing and so when he goes with with
writer being attacked
sun god responds and writer says you
still under like you finally understand
what's going on you finally see what's
happening here
it could not have been any other way and
with that sun god
lashes out and the battle is on with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end
if you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob corps if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like cliffhangers
and i'll catch you all later
peace
[Music]
one
[Music]
you